I have to apologize to you today.
I made a mistake on a story, I got a story
wrong and I want to fix it today.
Donald Trump has been floating the idea.
Of cutting the employee side of the payroll
tax for the rest of the year as a way to get
more money in people's pockets.
People earning under one hundred and thirty
eight thousand dollars per year.
I have multiple times said I was supportive
of this idea because it is true that it would,
in the immediate, put money back in the pockets
of workers earning under one hundred and thirty
eight thousand dollars a year.
But I was wrong to support it.
I was wrong.
And I'm going to explain why today.
Now, for people who don't know why or what
the payroll taxes.
If you are a normal W-2 employee, you're not.
You don't work for yourself.
You're not a small business owner.
You just work somewhere like most people do.
You and your employer share some taxes that
come off of your payroll.
Up until you earn one hundred and thirty seven
thousand seven hundred dollars per year, once
you get to 1:37 seven per year, you no longer
pay these taxes.
There are two taxes twelve point four percent
towards Social Security and 2.9 percent for
Medicare.
OK, it only is on the first one hundred and
thirty seven point seven thousand dollars
a year that you earn.
That is a total twelve point four and 2.9.
That's about fifteen point three percent.
The worker pays half and the employer pays
half.
So the fifteen point three percent is split.
Seven point six.
Five percent for you.
Seven point six five percent for the employer.
Trump's idea was let's suspend the employee
half seven point sixty five percent through
the end of the year.
But you would have to pay for it when you
file your taxes in 2021 for this year.
So it is not a cut.
It is a tax holiday.
Now, initially I said, listen, I do like it
because it puts money directly back in the
hands of people earning under one hundred
and thirty eight thousand dollars a year.
Right now, it is not a tax cut for the rich.
And I thought it was a good idea.
I was wrong to support it for three different
reasons.
And most importantly, this is another way
to actually backhandedly weaken Social Security
and Medicare.
And I want to go through each of these reasons
one by one.
So three parts here.
Number one, the people who are in the roughest
shape right now are the 35 ish million people
who lost their jobs.
If you lost your job, you're not paying a
payroll tax because you don't have a job.
So 7.6, 5 percent tax holiday off the payroll
tax for people who aren't on any payroll is
not useful at all.
Second, the people who do have jobs are mostly
earning the same amount of money now.
I'm not saying they wouldn't love not to pay
the 7.6 5 percent, but you've got 35 million
people that straight up lost their jobs.
So to them, the payroll tax holiday doesn't
make a difference.
Most people, fortunately for now, are still
working and have not seen a decrease in pay.
Some people are still working, but have seen
a decrease in pay.
But it is not that many people.
The bulk of the workers right now have not
seen a decrease in pay or are completely unemployed
and thus unaffected by a payroll tax holiday.
And the number three.
It is only a tax holiday.
This is not a tax cut.
If you weren't one hundred thousand dollars,
for example, in a year, that means in the
second half of the year you would expect to
earn about $50000 for now, saving seven point
six five percent puts thirty eight hundred
dollars back in your pocket.
But it is only a tax holiday when you file
your taxes in 2021 and you punch in how much
you've paid for Social Security and Medicare,
Turbo Tax or whatever, your accountant, whoever
will spit out, hey, that thirty eight hundred
dollars you didn't pay in the second half
of twenty twenty.
You've got to pay it back in right now because
it was only a tax holiday.
So doing this payroll tax cut would target
a relatively small group.
It would deprive the government of $950 billion
in revenue through the end of the year.
It would weaken social security and Medicare,
which could then open the door to dirty tricks
from people like Trump and Larry Kudlow and
others to say, hey, we've got to do something
with Social Security and Medicare.
We don't have that much money because of the
tax holiday you put in place and you've still
got to pay it back next year so we can't let
them do it.
I apologize that I was supportive of this
early on.
Given everything we now know, I cannot in
good conscience support this.
And I'm sorry that I suggested that it would
have been a good idea.
We're going to continue following this on
Instagram.
Our Instagram is David Pakman show.
You can also follow me on Instagram personally,
a tabletop Pacman.
We'll take a quick break and be back right
after this.
The David Pakman Show David Pakman dot.com.